si la crise sanitaire a changé nos
habitudes elle permet aussi de
développer la créativité de certains
entreprises ou particuliers ont innové
depuis un an
c'est le cas d'un jeune homme étudiant
guyancourt toile et au merlot grâce à
son imprimante 3d il a créé des poignées
de portes antico vide
au lieu d'utiliser sa main pour ouvrir
la porte on utilise désormais son bras
dès la rentrée de septembre 2020 les
écoles de guyancourt en ont été équipés
un nouveau moyen de ne pas se contaminer
en plus des gestes barrières
quelques mois plus tard c'est à fontenay
le fleury qu'une nouvelle innovation
voit le jour l'entreprise piot drones
invente une machine tueuse de co vide
grâce à la technologie des uv ces deux
dispositifs l'inde est infecte les
pièces le second se charge des petits
objets une technologie intéressante mais
qui nécessite des précautions les uvc à
hautes doses peuvent être dangereux pour
l'homme
toujours dans les yvelines attrape ou la
start up here captifs utilise la
technologie des voiles de surf pour
créer une tante ultralégère déployables
n'importe où en 40 minutes et surtout
stérile une innovation conçue en huit
jours avec l' expertise d'atmosphère
contrôlée du groupe aura nos de saint
quentin en yvelines
surnommé l' attente qu vide elle a pour
objectif d'accueillir des patients
positifs ou encore de monter très
rapidement un centre de dépistage ce fut
le cas sur l'autoroute a13
après les fêtes de fin d'année autre
innovation et pas des moindres
l'entreprise rick norrec situé à plaisir
à trouver une solution pour répondre à
la problématique du recyclage des
masques cet accessoire qu'il est
désormais obligatoire de porter partout
dans les yvelines en extérieur comme en
intérieur
elle et ses deux semaines à température
ambiante pour des contaminations
une expérimentation de ce recyclage
novateur a été lancée avec la mairie de
plaisir pendant trois mois
[Musique]